so
there are there are two a4 isms that are
relevant to thinking about teaching a
seminar I think one is I can't remember
who first said this but that the only
thing a Yale student remembers from a
seminar is what they themselves said in
it and then the other is a story about a
Harvard professor now deceased a
political theorist who used to walk into
her graduate seminars Judith's Laura
some of you may have read some other
books with and her opening remark was
you can talk for as long as you make
sense and then she would interrupt
everybody in the second sentence so
there's a tension between the the the
implications of those two I guess we
should stick with the format suggested
by Miroslav so I'll mainly talk for the
first 15 minutes and then we'll go to
questions but if anyone really is moved
to try and to interrupt me feel free
debate the basic message behind my
comments today might be thought to be
provocative and I think it's a something
somewhat contrarian with respect to the
themes of this course my basic message
is that both globalization and the
importance of faith or religion are
greatly overhyped in the current
discussion overhyped in the popular
literature and in in much of the
academic literature and I'm going to say
a little bit about why I think that in
both cases I'll start off with
globalization now one sense in which
globalization has been overhyped was was
brought out by Doug's commentary on Tom
Friedman's world being flat sometimes I
think arguing about whether or not the
world is flat is a little bit like
arguing over whether or not the number 7
is orange but perhaps it's more the case
that that it's flatter in some respects
and it's more hilly in other respects
and so the question is you know
which of the relevant respects and what
do they really tell us about the ongoing
distribution of power and Welfare and
political stability in the world and how
should we think about that and I think
that Doug makes the very valid point
that most economic activity still goes
on within nation states most goods and
services are produced by national
workforces operating under national
labor labor law regimes and that's all
true despite the increasing mobility of
capital and the declining trade barriers
and so on so I think that that is the
case but I think it's overhyped in a
different sense that focuses more on the
political economy of globalization not
the sheer economics of globalization
although I think more could be said
about the economics of globalization
simple proper and that I think we
actually now are witnessing something of
a retreat from economic globalization
towards regionalization of the world
economy but I'm no economist and so I
won't go there
in any detail now but I think that one
important lesson to draw from the events
of the last year and a half in the
world's political economic order is that
the key responses to the global
financial crisis did not come from
international political institutions or
international economic institutions the
key responses that to the to the global
economic crisis came from national
governments anybody who thinks that
national political systems of
diminishing importance in the world are
missing I think the most important fact
political fact of the of the
International landscape the the the most
important decisions were taken by
sovereign states to some extent in
agreement with one another because they
were all running scale
in the same direction but nonetheless
they were decisions taken principally
aimed at salvaging the the national
economies for which these governments
were responsible and they continue to do
so and I think that as the as the
interests of different national
populations start to diverge as people
retreat from the sort of panic that the
wheels are coming off the entire system
I think you're going to see more
divergence of interest we've already
seen an uptick in in protectionist
activity I think you'll see more of that
and the reassertion of national
sovereignty as a way of combating what's
been going on so although though it's
certainly true that this
interconnectedness of economic problems
of the problems that generated this
crisis and the there there's also a lot
of knock-on effects of the policies
particular governments pursue in
response to it we should we shouldn't
discount the importance of national
political systems in the world
so that means attending to the nature of
national political systems and that I
think inevitably puts democracy on the
table the question whether or not
democratic political systems are the
best response best able to respond to
the problems of globalization and I
think that I'll just I'll just say a few
things about that democratic political
systems are often criticised as being
not very good at dealing with ongoing
problems of political economy
Amartya Sen may made the observation
once that the democracy is a good thing
because on the grounds that we never
have famines in democracies but I think
that the example is is actually sort of
two-sided one because what it
underscores is
that democracies are pretty good at
responding to crises what they're not
very good as it is responding to chronic
problems so yes we don't get famines in
democracy but we do get poverty in
democracies we're not very good at
responding to chronic problems so while
the financial crisis was perceived to be
at crisis levels we got very rapid
response out of the democratic systems
but as it's now as the sense that the
wheels are coming off the world has gone
away it's proving much harder and you
see now the Obama administration can't
even get its resolution trust
legislation through Congress so he's
essentially leaving us with a situation
where we've now publicly admitted that
we have economic institutions that are
too big to fail but we neither have the
nerve to regulate them nor to break them
up so we haven't really resolved the
problem at all so in that sense
democracies might not very be very good
at dealing with with chronic problems
nonetheless those who say so we should
have benevolent authoritarian systems
and you know the system du jour is China
China looks like it did pretty well in
this crisis even in 2008 they're not
going to have double-digit growth but
they are going to have 8% growth in
China this year yes they had
unemployment problems but they're
already beginning to reverse and so I
think we're going to hear a lot of hype
about China in the coming year months
and years as an example of why we should
have authoritarian thinking and this is
this is a point that comes and goes in
in world politics in the 1970s and 1980s
there was a lot of discussion of
democracy as a kind of luxury good that
there would be a democracy tax on growth
that that we we have to pay if we're
going to have democracy and that the the
in those days it was the only
East Asian miracles that were put on the
table as as showing the virtues of
authoritarian capitalism rather than
democratic capitalism and even within
democratic systems countries like Japan
were held out as capable of much better
macroeconomic management and it was
widely noted in connection with this
that Japan had had the same political
party in powers for many decades and so
didn't face the normal challenges of
democratic politics but as a set at the
same time as Japanese success was being
hyped in fact they were piling up one
poor allocation decision after another
because authoritarian systems don't have
good access access to good information
one of the good things markets do is
generate information as a byproduct of
competition and so although everybody
was completely but completely wowed by
the Japanese economy in the 1970s and
and and first half of the 1980s the
chickens finally had came home to roost
in the 1990s when it was seen that they
had been propping up wildly inefficient
industries and were incapable of
competing with the more market-based
competitive systems I suspect that
there's a lot similar going on with
respect to China now that massive miss
allocations of investment are starting
to go on it's very easy in the earliest
stages of industrialization to know what
to do of course the Chinese have to
invest in education and infrastructure
but once you get beyond that
government's trying to pick winners
don't do very well over time and so
betting on authoritarian capitalism is
the wave of the future probably not a
great idea and people should remind
themselves that some of the democracies
have done just as well India for example
a very challenged democracy in many
respects nonetheless is whether this
crisis exceedingly well it's gonna have
6% growth rates this year
Canada has fit weather it well so the
temptation the temptations of
authoritarian globalization since we're
talking the language of temptations
shouldn't be I think
resisted let me say a few things about
faith and all that and religion there's
been a debate at least since Tocqueville
wrote democracy in America about whether
or not religion is good or bad for
democracy and if it is good
what variants of it is good and if it is
bad what variants of it are bad
Tocqueville for example thought
Catholicism was better for democracy
than Protestantism for a variety of
reasons I think the main one was that
once you have a democracy you no longer
have the authoritative allocation of
values by the state and so you need some
other hierarchical order for creating
values in society but in in subsequent
years it actually became more
fashionable to say that Catholicism was
less hospitable to democracy than
Protestantism but then of course we had
the democratization of much of Latin
America so people began revising that
notion that Catholicism was not
particularly hospitable to democracy
since we had many Catholic democracies
and actually of course we go back into
the the combating fascism there were
certainly many Catholics who opposed
fascism in Italy and elsewhere so it
seemed like a more mixed story we've had
a something of a replay of this whole
debate given want given the rise of
Islam as whether is Islam inherently
opposed to democracy some would say yes
some would say no and we have Huntington
wheeling out his
Clash of Civilizations and so on my own
view of this is that there are variants
of all religions that are compatible
with democracy and their variants of all
religions that are incompatible with
democracy because religion is not
particularly important either way with
respect to the survival of democracy
rather two other things are way more
important than religion
the first is economics and the two are
connected the first one is economics and
it is that the by far the best predictor
of whether or not democracies will
survive or is economic basically the the
big finding in the literature is that as
per capita incomes rise toward about
$6,000 a year in 1985 dollars
democracies become less and less likely
to collapse and once per capita income
goes above that level democracy survives
forever once democracies fall below that
level they become more and more
vulnerable and the further they fall
below it the more vulnerable they become
to the point where they very become very
likely to fall apart and be replaced by
something other than another democracy
namely some sort of
arianism so democracy becomes stable if
if you have economic growth and growth
in per capita incomes and elude just
alluding to Doug's slide about
inequality the more equal the less
inequality there is the more that helps
as well as inequality diminishes it
helps as well there's not a lot of
disagreement about that fund about the
existence of that finding there's a lot
of disagreement about why it's true but
the the finding is very robust and
things like culture beliefs institutions
all those things tend to be
a very small part of the variance next
to the economic datum I just gave you
the state-of-the-art is a book on this
if you're interested is a book called
democracy and development with
development and democracy and American
never remember which by Adam Schiff or
ski and variety of co-authors I can give
people more references if they want my
own view about why this is true connects
to the second point I want to make about
what's important in democracy and will
link us back to the religion and that is
as countries become richer you have less
what I would call winner-take-all
politics and when it take all politics
is is bad because it causes people to
try to get monopoly control of the
political system so when Al Gore
discovers that he is not going to become
President of the United States in
January of 2001 there are many other
things Al Gore can do to become happy
and successful and have lots of prestige
and influence in the world he can go on
book to us
he can read lead environmental movements
he can be on the lecture circuit he can
be on corporate boards there are many
other ways for Al Gore to win right but
in most poor countries the political
system is the only game in town so if
you get kicked out of the politics you
essentially are out of luck right and so
politics tends to be winner-take-all
politics I think that the the analog
here with religion that is important is
that it's not so much whether or not
religion exists in the political in in
the political system but rather whether
or not being a member of a particular
religion will
puts you in a position to engage in
winner-take-all politics so it doesn't
matter whether or not there's an
established church so much as whether
it's necessary to be a member of the
established church in order to have
security and prosperity in the society
so we have an established church in the
UK but it's not necessary to be part of
it in order to be successful in that
society on the other hand if you have a
fundamentalist regime it's both
exclusionary and it involves
winner-take-all politics you have to be
part of it it's it's the equivalent of
you know it's the only game in town and
that's what becomes the threat to the
survival of a democratic political order
how are we doing on time yeah okay so
that I probably put enough out there but
the so the the the bottom line is that I
think as I said at the outset that
there's this rather too much hype around
globalization and I think people are
trying to have been trying to load a lot
more significance onto the whole matter
of religion in well politics than is
warranted and I think I'll just close
with the observation that in some way in
one way it's understandable you know if
you go back to the 1950s everybody was
jumping up and down about something
called modernization theory the basic
idea of modernization theory was that
the the Schumpeterian logic of he called
it creative destruction the creative
destruction of markets if you guys read
John Pater yeah which slowly just grind
under traditional practices all forms of
non market rationality would ultimately
succumb to the creative destruction of
capitalism there were earlier Marxist
variants of this as
and and there were many besides
Schumpeter Seymour Martin Lipset and our
own David after all pushed this idea in
the 50s and 60s that it was a kind of
early version of of Tom Friedman in a
way that you know they were going to be
these homogenizing forces and that
turned out not to be right
the politics of modernization are
multifaceted and many sided I think a
lot of the resurgence of identity
politics is in fact a response to the
forces of economic globalization from
the losers because if you're a winner
it's great but if you were a loser
there's not much in globalization for
you why don't I stop there and you can
all tell me why I'm wrong